nous sommes actuellement à châlons en
champagne pour passer les oraux du capes
d'histoire-géographie qui se déroule
dans un hommage à lise là je passe mes
euros demain et après demain j'ai pas
tant tourner une vidéo
mais on devait faire une vidéo sur
comment devenir propre on la fera quand
alors plus tard dans ce cas bonne
révision
enfin peu accéléré de votants voilà on
peut commencer
dans cette vidéo nous allons comprendre
comment accéder aux métiers de
l'enseignement
si vous êtes intéressés par ces métiers
ou pour votre culture générale ou si
vous êtes jeune et innocent et que vous
voulez savoir tout ce que vos profs ont
enduré pour en arriver jusqu'à vous
commençons par les études après le bac
vous devez tout d'abord passer une
licence dans la matière que vous
préférez et de préférence la matière que
vous souhaitez enseigner ensuite
soyons logique pure et donc une licence
d'histoire ou de géo pour être prof
d'histoire-géo une licence de maths pour
être prof de maths une licence de latin
pour être au chômage etc
au terme de ces trois années de licence
vous devez aussi obtenir un master pour
cela vous est proposée le master des
métiers de l'enseignement de l'éducation
et de la formation que ses amis
appellent master mef
il se prépare en deux ans comme un
master et a pour but de vous former au
métier d'enseignant et au concours que
vous allez devoir passer surtout au
concours en fait parce que ça sera votre
principale préoccupation pendant tout
votre master d'autant plus qu'il est
rare d'avoir son capes du premier coup
surtout en histoire
la première année du master mef consiste
donc en des périodes de formation de
cours est également des stages ou si
votre tuteur est gentil vous serez amené
à faire vos premiers vrais cours face à
des élèves l'occasion de vous rendre
compte que suit le cours que vous aviez
préparé ne dure que 40 minutes et vous
êtes comme un conte face à vos élèves ou
encore dix ans entre le débat que je
voulais lancer sur les médias est aussi
vivant que michael jackson
enfin je crois à la fin de cette
première année vous passerez le capes et
si vous avez de la chance vous serez
déjà dans le métier pendant votre
deuxième année en fait durant votre m2
vous alternez entre un mi-temps et des
temps de formation donc vous bossez tout
en validant votre master et à la fin de
l'année vous êtes titulariser ça y est
vous êtes prof
à vous les joies de la photocopieuse en
panne et les vacances a ravagé durant
lesquelles vous préparer des cours et
corriger vos copies non mais je ne
pourrais pas dire grand chose de plus
sur ce master mef parce que je n'ai pas
fait voilà mais en gros c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
pour ma part j'ai fait un master
recherche en histoire dont j'ai résumé
le sujet dans une formidable vidéo que
vous retrouverez dans les liens
l'avantagé d'avoir un master recherche
c'est qui m'a permis de passer le capes
sans avoir à passer par le master mef
parce que c'est quand même plus sympa de
déchiffrer des vieux documents aux
archives nationales que d'apprendre si
oui ou non on doit faire sortir de
classe un élève qui aurait mordu son
voisin ok c'était pas ça ma motivation
je voulais juste faire de la recherche
avec
nous allons maintenant nous intéresser
au capes à proprement parler ce concours
se déroule en deux séries d'épreuves des
écrits et des oraux le concours portera
à la fois sûr de l'histoire est sûre de
la géographie et vous aurez trois sujets
dans chacune de ces deux épreuves qui
peuvent tomber
on connaît des sujets un an à l'avancé
voire plus puisque la plupart des sujets
restent plusieurs années de suite en
place pour cette session 2016 les sujets
d'histoire sont donc le monde romain de
moins 70 à 73 après jésus-christ
gouverner en islam du 10e au xvème
siècle et citoyenneté république
démocratie de 1789 à 1899 en géographie
il s'agit de l'union indienne des mers
et océans et des mutations des systèmes
productifs en france ce sont les sujets
pour lesquels vous serez interrogé aux
écrits et pour l'un des 2 euros il vous
faudra donc en apprendre le plus
possible dessus voici donc ma précieuse
liste de conseils pour chaque sujet par
exemple pour citoyenneté république et
démocratie au 19e siècle vous pouvez
commencer par 1789 les amants de la
bastille avec ça je suis sûr que vous
saurez tout sur la révolution française
ensuite vous pouvez continuer avec
germinal avec renault toujours debout
comme ça vous connaît très bien les
mouvements ouvriers tout ça vous
trouverez pas ça dans le rapport du jury
tout ce que je vous donne ce sont des
conseils unique pour l'histoire antique
je vous aurais bien dit de regarder
spartacus parce que c'est une bonne
série mais c'est hors période dommage
du coup vous pouvez regarder rome est
comme ça vous êtes calais pour
l'histoire antique pour gouverner en
islam
j'ai pas de conseils à la con qui me
viennent en tête en fait va falloir
ouvrir un manuel comme tout le monde
non mais mais bon on se rattrape avec la
géographie achetez vous un bon manuel de
coloriage pour apprendre à dessiner sans
dépasser les contours vous voilà
cartographe vous pourrez toujours
bachoter l'union indienne devant slumdog
millionaire ou sinon plus sérieusement
il ya la saison des femmes qui est sorti
récemment quitté un très bon film râler
contre les mutations des systèmes
productifs en allant voir merci patron
quoi de mieux que des usines qui ferment
dans un ancien bassin industriel pour
poser l'ambiance dans votre copie pour
les mers et océans c'est un peu plus
délicat
alors écoutez bien prenez des notes si
vous voulez océan indien océan pacifique
océan atlantique océan arctique océan
austral mehr méditerranée si vous voulez
vraiment être balèze voilà c'est bon
plus sérieusement si vous préparer le
capes d'histoire-géographie j'aurais pas
assez tout une vidéo pour vous expliquer
tout ce qu'il faut savoir connaître bien
les sujets lire les rapports du jury
pour connaître
moment des épreuves sur le bout des
doigts connaître les programmes
connaître aussi un petit peu de
didactique comment faire court connaître
l'historiographie l'épistémologie
geography enfin bref plein plein de
choses avant on va donc s'intéresser au
déroulement des épreuves
il y a deux épreuves écrites de cinq
heures chacune qui se déroule dans vos
tracas ling et 5h en fait ça passe très
vite quand on est en examen la première
épreuve est une composition tout ce
qu'il ya de plus classique qui portera
sur l'un des six sujets que je vous ai
présenté avant et qui consistera en
faire une introduction un plan une
conclusion si vous tombez sur de la
géographie il aura en plus un fond de
carte à compléter là par exemple j'ai
travaillé sur l'agriculture en france
enjoy pour varier les plaisirs si vous
tombez en histoire le premier jour des
épreuves vous aurez de la géographie le
lendemain et vice versa la deuxième
épreuve et dont un commentaire de
document doublée d'une adaptation
pédagogique ça devait un petit peu plus
compliqué vous devez donc dans un
premier temps analyser les documents en
tirait toutes les informations utiles en
faire un commentaire et compléter un
fond de carte si vous êtes en géographie
ah oui et si c'est de la géo que ça soit
en composition ou en commentaire de
document
il faut pas oublier de faire des petits
graphiques des schémas à des croquis ils
adorent ça les géographes ça fait bien
dans les copies est donc toujours dans
cette deuxième épreuve vous devez aussi
faire une adaptation pédagogiques
c'est-à-dire expliquer comment vous vous
en seriez ce sujet face à une classe par
exemple si vous tombez sur en histoire
gouverner en islam il faut enseigner ça
au cinquième parce que c'est un
cinquième qu'on étudie l'islam vous
devez donc expliquer des notions que
vous tenteriez d'apprendre aux élèves
quels documents vous utiliseriez comment
vous feriez votre cour le type
d'exercice la trace écrite
la marque du vidéoprojecteur et la note
que vous mettriez au petit enzo à la fin
de son contrôle autant dire que vous
devrez vous accrocher pour finir cette
épreuve en cinq heures mais je vous
rassure c'est possible et votre poignet
rendra l'âme seront utilisables pendant
les 15 jours qui suivent le chemin est
périlleux mais si vous réussissez cette
épreuve vous accéderez au saint graal de
quest pour
les oraux ce truc que l'autre est en
train de réviser là je suis submergé par
le stress pour cela vous devrez vous
déplacer en tout cas pour l'histoire géo
dans la charmante ville de châlons en
champagne qui voit tous ces hôtels
rempli un mois dans l'année grâce à moi
à nous avant ces épreuves se déroulent
sur trois jours le premier jour c'est
plutôt tranquille
vous serez convoqué à un tirage au sort
dans lequel vous saurez si votre
première épreuve sera de l'histoire ou
de la géo 6,7 l'histoire le lendemain
vous aurez la géo et vice versa on
commence à connaître pendant cette
première journée vous serez également
autorisés à visiter la bibliothèque
pendant une heure et pas une minute de
plus ce qui vous permettra de repérer
les ouvrages que vous pourrez emprunter
le lendemain pour préparer votre épreuve
tous les coups sont permis n'hésitez pas
à vous emparer en premier d'un
dictionnaire ou d'un atlas pour assommer
vos concurrents par contre vous êtes
limité à 5 livres
alors n'oubliez pas de le reposer avant
de partir si vous n'en avez pas besoin
et s'il reste des morceaux de vos
concurrents dessus durant ce premier
jour il ne se passe donc pas grand chose
et si vous reste du temps vous pouvez
vous inscrire pour assister aux oraux
des autres histoires de le remettre bien
la pression n'hésitez pas à bâiller et à
faire des petits signes de la tête
négatif quand ils répondent à des
questions
le lendemain matin c'est le grand jour
vous tirez le sujet de l'épreuve une de
mise en situation professionnelle
alors cette année ça dépend ça peut très
bien commencer par la deuxième épreuve
c'est nouveau mais enfin normalement
c'est comme ça encore une fois cette
épreuve repose sur l'un des six thèmes
que vous avez dû réviser pendant l'année
après un petit tour à la bibliothèque et
environ quatre heures de préparation ça
y est vous passez votre oral vous avez
trente minutes 20 minutes d'exposé
classique et 10 minutes d'adaptation
pédagogiques ou comme pour les écrits
vous expliquer comment vous adaptez
auriez ce sujet face à une classe dans
la douleur vous avez ensuite 30 minutes
de questions face au jury
la deuxième épreuve le lendemain
s'appelle analyse de situation
professionnelle
est ce que je peux en dire c'est que
c'est compliqué ça consiste en analyse
et des extraits de manuels des documents
scientifiques et un texte qui aura plus
tôt une porte et d'éducation civique
enfin bref c'est compliqué je crois que
si je rentre davantage dans le sujet je
serai confuse confuse entre vous serez
confus en tout cas vous aurez un dossier
documentaire quatre heures de
préparation est à nouveau 30 minutes de
passage à l'oral et trente minutes
d'entretien avec le jury le but de cette
épreuve sera plutôt de montrer que vous
avez des connaissances sur
l'historiographie et d'épistémologie et
que vous savez les relier avec les
programmes vous avez relier la recherche
scientifique dans l'histoire grange et
où est ce qu'on trouve dans les manuels
en gros et voilà une fois que vous avez
fini ça vous êtes libre parle pour toi
et potentiellement bientôt profs pour
cela vous devrez attendre les résultats
début juillet si vous êtes admis vous
serez envoyé dans un collège ou un lycée
quelque part en france pour être prof en
rendez vous la prochaine fois pour les
pirates de blended c'est quoi le guen
come back
si vous voulez vraiment devenir prof et
voulez en savoir plus sur le déroulement
du concours vous pouvez me poser des
questions dans les commentaires j'ai
répondu merci